it's a forest of concrete a desolate
Council estate in Marseille home to 9
000 people similar to many others around
France
Urban Muhammad lived here during her
teenage years it was very different she
says
she shows us where one stood a
commercial center
almost no one wants to speak to us or be
filmed we get interrupted several times
there was infrastructure there were
social workers I was one of them and we
did good work now there is a parallel
business drug dealing there are more and
more killings No One Is Safe parents are
children how can you grow up under these
conditions
president Emmanuel macron hinted that
parents could be penalized in the future
for their children's doing
is unfair says 19 years old Amin casasi
his brother was torched alive inside a
vehicle by a local drug gang after he
tried to walk away it's called a
Marseille barbecue
the family grew up in the northern part
of the city consider it as the toughest
neighborhood
my sister is in the Army she fought for
France in Senegal so why would they
punish my mother she educated my sister
and my brother in the same way my
brother took this path because there are
bigger issues the Estates here are
open-air prisons ghettos where you grow
up and stay the only employers here are
drug traffickers
part of the problem is the lack of
neighborhood policing it was abolished
in 2005.
many complained that since then their
neighborhoods are becoming every day
more dangerous and relationship with the
regular police has become very tense
this woman is a part of grieving mothers
who met with the French President just a
week before the riots happened her son
was gunned down in broad daylight in
2018. his final agonizing moments
broadcast live on social media
it is very difficult to be a mother
under these conditions we were
completely abandoned I will never forget
those images and I take it really badly
when I hear they want to make a lot to
punish the parents they don't know how
we educate our children who are they to
criticize us we do everything we can to
protect our children
the reason riots have put the spotlight
on part of the population that has never
been really considered French there is
deep mistrust and many of them now fear
that if a law really passes it will not
apply to all French citizens foreign